[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Hello,
data developers.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Michael
Manoochehri.
I work with the Developer
Relations team, supporting
data products like BigQuery.
And today, I'm joined by Kim
Cameron, a developer relations
person working in Seattle
with the BigQuery team.
Hi, Kim.
How are you?
KIM CAMERON: No, I'm doing
well, Michael.
How are you?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's great.
I'm doing great.
What's the weather
like in Seattle?
KIM CAMERON: It is
rainy, Michael.
I know this is a shock.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: [LAUGHS]
So cool.
It's usually raining
in Seattle.
Today we're going to be
talking about some new
BigQuery features.
But for those who haven't used
it yet, BigQuery is an API
that allows you to ask
questions, run queries, on
very large data sets.
We're talking things like
gigabytes and terabytes.
Now one of the things we've
tried to do with Google
BigQuery is to simplify the
lives of data developers.
When you're normally working
with very large data sets, you
often have to manage your own
infrastructure, buy expensive
equipment, or do data
transformations.
And with BigQuery, one of the
advantages to using it is that
the service is hosted on
our infrastructure.
And by using the SQL LIKE
queries, it allows you to run
these queries very easily.
So today we're going to talk a
little bit about some of the
new features that we're
launching today.
And Kim, do you want to tell
us some of the new features
that we're going to
be talking about?
KIM CAMERON: Absolutely.
So we're going to talk about
four features today.
First of all, we now have the
ability to use the timestamp
data type instead
of regular Unix
timestamps and date strings.
You can now add columns to
your tables schemas.
And we have two really important
updates to the JOIN
and GROUP BY operations
that Michael is going
to talk about first.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes.
So let's talk about joins.
So when you're dealing with a
lot of data, very large data
sets, what we try to do with
BigQuery is allow you to run
these queries very quickly
on these data sets.
Imagine if you're an e-commerce
site and you've got
millions or thousands of user
IDs, and you have another data
set full of transactions,
purchases.
And you want to gain some
insight by combining these
data sets together.
Now this kind of data process
is usually something in the
realm of data transformation.
You'd use something like
Hadoop, MapReduce.
You may be using a lot of
expensive infrastructure or
even waiting a long time for
these things to happen.
But relational database people
are very used to running JOINS
across different tables
or grouping by
many different buckets.
So with BigQuery, we've tried
to make this simpler.
We want to extend.
We've heard from our developers
who have told us
they want to extend the
simplicity of BigQuery to
other use cases.
And one of the most common use
cases we've heard from is to
extend BigQuery's ability to run
these queries, not just on
one large data set,
but multiple.
In the past, BigQuery has
supported what we call small
joins, which is a large table
joined with a smaller table,
like a look-up table.
But today we're announcing a new
feature called Big JOIN,
which allows you to actually
merge data results from two
large data sets.
We're also rolling out a new
feature we call Big Group
Aggregations, which allows you
to group by a very large
amount of individual
common records.
For example, grouping results
by each of the
individual user records.
And to do this, we've added a
new clause that Kim's going to
talk about.
KIM CAMERON: So that's actually
the keyword, EACH.
Which you can add
to your queries.
And that activates these
new features.
And this isn't to say that you
wouldn't want to use the
regular GROUP BY or the
regular JOIN anymore.
There are use cases for using
one or the other.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
That's right.
Like I said before, the original
JOIN was really great
when you had a large table
and a small table.
And when you have that actual
use case, you should still use
JOIN without JOIN EACH,
or GROUP BY
without GROUP EACH BY.
And I'll demonstrate
some of these
queries in just a second.
When you have a lot of different
keys, you're going
to have to use the JOIN EACH.
And let me demonstrate
that right now.
So why don't we go to the query
window, and Kim I will
demonstrate an example
of this query.
So here, if you can see,
our BigQuery WebUI--
when you sign up for BigQuery,
you have access to this web
interface to run your
own queries.
We also have public data sets
that you can query.
I'm going to show you a
public data set here.
It's our Google Books
Ngrams data set.
It has trigrams, which are
really just collections of
three words.
And this particular data set
we have is 258 gigabytes.
And I'm going to run a query
that matches, merges data by
common key with our Wikipedia
revision data set.
That data set's about
35 gigabytes.
So we're going to
do a JOIN query.
Now let me run this without
JOIN EACH, and
you'll see what I mean.
JOIN is for a large
query running--
joining with a smaller table.
So let's run this.
So it's going to
throw an error.
It's going to say, this
table is too large
for a regular JOIN.
So now let's use the
JOIN EACH clause.
And we'll let this run.
And we'll talk about
what's happening.
So this is adding an additional
processing step,
which is actually making sure
that we can join these two
tables by the common key, which
is the Wikipedia title
and a particular Ngram.
I've thrown in a string function
here to actually
normalize the data.
Some of the Wikipedia titles
have title case.
And some of the Ngrams
have lowercase.
So I'm just running that over
all the records that we're
joining against.
And I'm saying, return
the top five.
And there we go.
That took merely 27 seconds.
It processed all of that data.
And it's given us the five
examples of Ngrams that are
also popularly revised
Wikipedia titles.
So now you know.
This is just using the
public data sets.
I think a better example would
be what Kim was talking about
earlier with some of these
e-commerce examples.
So Kim, can you tell us a little
bit about what you
might do in an e-commerce
example that would
make sense with this?
KIM CAMERON: So, one example
would be let's say I store
user information in one data
set and then I also store
order information in
other data set.
So each of those orders is going
to have an associated
customer ID.
And now, what happens if I want
to aggregate all of that
information about a customer?
I'm going to have to join two
really big data sets,
especially if I'm a really big
e-commerce site, and I have
millions of users.
And that's going to be a
challenge to use with the
regular JOIN.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
And I think a lot of people have
been using things like
MapReduce or some kind of
transformation tool to first
denormalize this data,
so they could put it
in a tool like BigQuery.
But I think this really
enables you to do a
different use case.
It's something that stems
that simplistic
model in larger tables.
And I think it really
opens up a lot of
new ways to use BigQuery.
KIM CAMERON: And how about
the GROUP BY example?
Do you have one of those.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
So the GROUP BY is actually
almost exactly the same.
And another example, we
could do things like--
I don't actually have one
queued up-- but we could
actually do things like run a
query where we want to look at
every Wikipedia title and
group something by each
Wikipedia title.
In the past, BigQuery didn't
support this type of grouping.
The GROUP BY had a limit.
But now, if you use GROUP EACH
BY, that kind of query doesn't
actually have a limit.
You can pipe out sort of any
amount of bucketing that you
want, as long as it
fits within our
maximum result set size.
So that's it.
You can use them in conjunction
as well.
So it's really interesting.
You can create these joined
table results and then run a
GROUP BY on the resulting
table.
There's lots of great things
you can do with this.
Really great for mobile game
developers and, as you said,
e-commerce sites.
KIM CAMERON: Absolutely.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Really
interesting use cases there.
KIM CAMERON: So next let's
talk about timestamp.
So in the past, BigQuery has had
date and time functions to
deal with things like Unix
timestamps and also date
strings, ways to parse date
strings, et cetera.
And this is good.
You could technically get that
information from Unix
timestamps or date strings.
But let's say you wanted to
store timestamp data on your
end, and you wanted to put
that into BigQuery.
In the past, you haven't
been able to do this.
And you've had to do
one of two things.
One, you could actually change
the data in your database.
So you could start storing Unix
timestamps instead of a
timestamp data type
like in MySQL.
So that's option one.
Option two is you could actually
transform your data
before you load it
into BIgQuery.
And then that's an additional
step that you'd have to do
every single time.
So again, we wanted to listen
to you as developers and try
to make your lives
easier with this.
So we've rolled out
the addition of a
timestamp data type.
And what that means is, now you
can keep your timestamps
in your database.
And you can load them into
BigQuery as time stamps.
There's a few advantages
to doing this.
First of all, obviously, you
don't have to do that
transformation step, which is
going to save you time.
Additionally, you can specify a
time zone when you load your
data into Big Query.
So you can preserve that
bit of metadata.
Additionally, if you ever stored
your data as a date
string, it's kind of tricky to
parse that information out, if
you wanted to really easily get
things like, what's the
month, what's the year.
So by using BigQuery's built-in
timestamp functions,
you can just say, month.
And you can get the month
of the timestamp.
So that makes your life--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
I like this use case that
supports the idea that you can
have different time zones in
your timestamps.
Maybe you're collecting data
from different servers, like
one on the East Coast of
the United States,
one on the West Coast.
KIM CAMERON: Absolutely.
And finally, it's a
lot more readable.
So I don't know about you, but
unless you're a math savant
like Michael--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Or like Kim.
KIM CAMERON: --reading Unix
timestamps in records is not
very readable.
So let's say you want to query
your data in BigQuery and you
want to see the date actually
in the result.
By keeping it in timestamp
format,
it's going to be readable.
So those are some of the reasons
why timestamp, we
think, is going to be helpful.
And Michael has an example.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
So if we go back to the BigQuery
WebUI, I'll show you
one of my favorite things about
the new timestamp data
type that Kim just
talked about.
One is you can cast strings
to timestamp.
And I'll show you an
example of that.
I'm actually going to
run three things
in one quick query.
You can cast to a timestamp
data type.
You can also timeshift, which
I think is very cool.
You can say, give me the
timestamp that is one hour or
one year away from a particular
timestamp.
So here I'm just going
to do that.
I picked a random timestamp.
And I'm going to show you the
string turn into a timestamp.
And as you can see here, we
list UTC at the bottom.
And then I've just selected a
date that's one hour ahead and
a date that's one year ahead.
Now Kim, I believe if you want
it to go backwards, you can
just add a negative number.
So I can re-run this query
with the same date.
And I'm going to say, give me
something one hour before and
one year before.
And there we go.
The query has just run.
And now I can actually
do timeshift.
So I can say things like, give
me everything from this date
to another date, so
within a range.
You can do things like that.
It's very useful for those
kind of applications.
And now let's take another
look at some real data.
We're going to go back to one
of our public data sets.
It's one of our most popular
that was curated by a Googler
on the Chrome team, [? Ilya ?]
[? Gregorich. ?]
It's our GitHub commit
history data set.
Here I'm just going to look
at the timestamps there.
We have these timestamps
in that data set
currently as strings.
And as Kim said, it's really
useful to change these into
timestamp data type, so we can
actually run the hour method,
which will pull out the hour of
the day that that timestamp
pertains to.
So here I'm going to look at all
of the records in GitHub,
when they were created--
I'm sorry, these are
events in GitHub--
when they were created.
And we're going to take the
timestamp, change it into the
timestamp data type, and
then pull out the hour.
And so what we're doing here is
we're trying to find which
hour of the day is most popular
for GitHub events?
And of course, this is in UTC.
Look, the queries here.
Looks like 1300 hours is UTC,
14, 16 is about the most
popular time for these
GitHub events.
You'd have to do a little
more data analysis
to figure out why.
But you can use this kind of
query to find out things like
that on your own data.
KIM CAMERON: And for any of
these functions, you can look
at the query reference.
There's a new section called
Date and Time Functions.
And that contains both all of
the old Unix timestamp data
string functions, as well as the
new timestamp functions.
And we've also added a new
column that has an example
query that you can run as
well as the result.
So if you want to remember how
to do the negative numbers or
any of these, you can just check
out the query reference
at any time.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
I like those samples a lot.
In fact, the samples I just ran,
I literally pulled some
of those right from the
new documentation.
So I'm pretty happy
about those.
KIM CAMERON: Oh great.
And then let's talk about the
column schema example.
So let's say you store your data
in either datastore, on
App Engine, or a
NoSQL solution.
And you do that, probably
because you want the
flexibility to be able to
add data on the fly.
So going back to the e-commerce
example, let's say
you store customer data and
you store zip codes.
And later on, you decide you
want to add the four-digit
extension as a new column.
You can do that on your end.
In the past, that wasn't
possible in BigQuery, because
once you load your data into
BigQuery, you're stuck with
that table schema.
We fixed that today.
And moving forward, by letting
you just update your tables
schema with the new column.
And it's just going to work.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
So to do this, you could
actually just reuse the
BigQuery API's Tables
Update method.
And all you have to do is run
that method on your table and
pass in the new schema, with the
additional columns added.
Records that you've already
had there are unaffected.
They become null values.
And you're able to have the
data in there before that
didn't have that schema and
extend that schema for the new
data coming in.
It's pretty great.
Another thing we're working on
is adding that functionality
to the BQ command-line tool.
This is the command-line
tool for BigQuery.
So we'll have that
out soon as well.
KIM CAMERON: And we'll
definitely keep you updated
once that's available.
So yeah, I think those are the
four features we wanted to
talk about.
One last piece of
info for you--
we've also been trying to
make information in the
documentation a lot more
accessible, especially for
things that are important to
you, like we know the query
reference is important to you.
And in the past it's been a
little bit buried in the docs.
So we're rolling out some new
doc changes today as well.
There is an overall plan.
It's going to get
a lot better.
For now, we've launched a few
new nodes in the top-level
navigation.
One is the loading data
in the BigQuery node.
This contains a few new
topics like preparing
your data for BigQuery.
So this gives examples of things
you might want to do on
your database and before
you load it.
We also have some content
on loading from
various data stores.
We also have a new
exporting topic.
And then, we've moved
the query reference
up to the top level.
It's now called Querying Data.
So you should be able to access
that a lot easier.
And if you have any feedback at
all in the documentation--
on things you like, things you
dislike, things you think are
hidden and you'd like them
[? bundled ?] up--
there's a Send Feedback link on
every documentation page.
And we do personally
read that feedback.
And we use it to make your
experience better.
So we really encourage
you to do that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
And before we go, let's talk
about how you can reach us in
other ways.
If you have developer questions,
you can ask them on
our official developer support
area, which is Stack Overflow.
We use the tag Google-BigQuery.
So just ask your questions
about BigQuery.
Tag them that way.
We have, not only us, but other
Google engineers read
that thread as well.
And we'd be happy
to talk to you.
Also, don't forget to follow
us on the Google Cloud
Platform Developers
Google+ page.
We're always posting there with
new features, new things
like that, and we'd
love to get your
feedback there as well.
So great.
So that wraps up our
new features.
Please send us feedback.
I hope you enjoy them.
And we'll be back again for
another data developers GDL.
KIM CAMERON: Indeed.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I'm
Michael Manoochehri.
KIM CAMERON: I am Kim Cameron.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
All right.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]